with joe biden obviously cognitively
impaired and struggling to communicate
the white house just rolled out a
popular actor to help with its messaging
surrounding gun violence now today
uvalde native matthew mcconaughey the
actor gave a very emotional speech about
the horrific shooting in his own
hometown take a look
and then the reality of what had
happened that day in the town i was born
and set in
so the next morning camilla myself the
kids would load up the truck and we told
you valve
when we arrived a few hours later
i got to tell you even from the inside
of our vehicle
you could you could feel the shock
in the town
you you could feel the pain
the denial the disillusion anger
blame sadness loss of life
dreams halted
that pain is real and it's happening way
too often around the country tonight we
do continue to pray for the families in
uvalde and every other city they'll
never be the same along with the
families of murder victims all across
the country in major cities like chicago
baltimore l.a new york we have dozens of
young men and women our national
treasure shot and killed every single
week but we rarely hear about this kind
of violence from democrats which is
where the political aspect comes in they
only seem to really care about gun
violence only when it becomes
politically expedient for them now keep
in mind almost all of america's most
violent cities have been ruled by
democrats for decades and every one of
those cities has some of the strictest
gun control laws in the country now
unfortunately democrats they love
passing laws they just don't like
applying them to dangerous criminals
that's a problem they have zero bail
laws lacks uh prosecution short
sentencing guidelines defunding
dismantling the police all directly
contributing to the carnage in all of
these cities but the white house doesn't
seem to care
they don't even bring in celebrities to
give impassioned speeches about the
deterioration of baltimore and they
should there are no dramatic calls for
action after a violent weekend in
chicago we have been chronicling all of
that since 2009 and scrolling names on
this program you never hear joe biden
screaming for lawmakers for god's sakes
do something after another round of
shootings in l.a and by the way you're
never going to hear a democrat talking
about the 2.5 million defensive gun uses
each year they result in countless lives
being saved now for the left this isn't
about saving lives or reducing violence
like always it is political and it's an
emotional ploy to centralize their power
over law-abiding citizens
and by the way many of them would like
to serve all second amendment rights
we've got to protect our constitution
and our right to defend ourselves
there's no doubt that matthew
mcconaughey i believe with all my heart
he had good intentions today and to his
credit he wants to help i give him a lot
of credit for that he also said things i
absolutely agree with democrats have
shown though over and over again they
don't care as they ignore the weekly
violence in democratic-run cities and
states and we only hear from them when
they believe they can politicize this
event or that event and ignore all the
weekly violence that takes place in
cities that they've been running and
it's very sad you know what since 2009
we have scrolled name after name after
name after name after name people you
never hear of people they never talk
about killed in chicago shot in chicago
new york la and they haven't lifted a
finger they barely mentioned it joe
biden barely mentioned it eight years as
vice president and today they were more
than happy to hide behind a very well
liked actor who to me seemed to have
very sincere intentions he gave a very
impassioned speech advocating for new
gun laws here's what he said
we know it's on the table
we need to invest in mental health care
we need to save for schools we need to
restrain sensationalized media coverage
we need to restore our family values
we need to restore
our american values
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
we need to raise the minimum age to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
221
we need a waiting period for those
rifles we need red flag laws and
consequences for those who abuse them
now on a follow-up interview right here
on fox mcconaughey gave his take on the
current negotiations on capitol hill and
here's what he said
you've had a number of talks on capitol
hill do you think that this is the time
do you think that this is somehow
different because we've been through it
before yes i've covered a lot of them
yes sir so look i don't have anything to
compare it to
up here on the hill but the consensus
word that i'm hearing and phrase is that
this time is different that there is
some more momentum that on the right
there are some things that they're
willing to not staunchly say no to and
consider that on the left they're
willing to say you know what we may want
the whole loaf but we can't we'll take
slice
as mcconaughey just said democrats are
content to get a slice now then what
another slice next year then another and
another and another until they have the
whole loaf and your gun rights and your
second amendment rights are gone hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else